the house of card syndrome has taken its
toll
we asked Americans if they were to guess
between zero and a hundred percent what
percentage of their elected officials
use their political power to hurt their
enemies and help their friends on
average Americans think 70 percent of
their elected officials use their
political power to hurt their enemies
and help their friends in addition we
asked Americans if they were to guess
between zero and a hundred what
percentage of their elected officials
are corrupted by special interests and
lobbyists and they said seventy five
percent of their elected officials are
probably corrupted by special interests
this is actually part of a broader
problem overwhelmingly Americans
disapprove of Congress a majority
disapprove of President Obama's job
performance and six in ten think we're
off on the wrong direction more and more
Americans are declining to affiliate
with either two of the major political
parties they feel that government is not
working government is losing some of the
romance that it used to have as people
learn about what people do when they
have political power
you